Hi everyone.
My name is Jonathan McIntosh.
I'm the curator of the Buffy versus Edward remix video.
I thought I put together a collection of the deleted scenes that didn't quite
make the final cut.
So here we go.
So this first scene was really just a test at the beginning of the project to
see if I could get Buffy and Edward interacting in a convincing way.
It serves no narrative purpose and so therefore wasn't in the final version.
But,
um,
I did use this sort of clip at the very end where Edward walks away.
Um,
as part of the narrative and the final piece,
I just need to spend all my time to walk a little while to get back into the
school.
Everybody's in a hurry.
Ultimately,
I couldn't fit all of these Scooby's all Buffy,
he's friends and mentors into the final piece.
It just was too hard to introduce them all,
make them make sense to people who hadn't seen Buffy and then drive the
narrative forward.
So they,
uh,
I ended up cutting out Giles and is mom.
But,
um,
I really loved this little clip.
Where's Andrew says,
you know,
I've read the book,
I've seen the movie and I still don't get it.
I'm obviously in this case referring to the twilight books.
I think it's very clear what's happening here.
Fill me in then because I've read the book seeing the movie and I'm still fuzzy
about what's going on.
Deadly and seductive demon.
He draws people to him with promises of love,
power and knowledge present impressionable mind.
There's something about this from that scares me.
I
don't have to be,
this is a really quick clip of Edward continuing his stocking of Buffy.
But in the end it didn't quite fit with the,
uh,
with the story.
This next clip is probably the longest of all the deleted scenes.
It's meant a show.
Edward escalating is stocking,
uh,
and buffets reaction to that.
But it does include Giles and Bobby's mom.
And since I cut them out of the narrative,
it didn't make any sense to include this scene.
And it also kind of interrupts the flow of,
of the final piece,
which is sort of very fast paced and,
and all about Buffy and Edward.
Yeah.
I was just checking the back porch.
Somebody young.
How obscene is that?
Something about me had to make him feel that,
right.
Something that made him say,
woof,
that's the one for me.
Does anyone else want to smack that guy?
This last little bit is an alternative last line,
the very end of the Remix,
uh,
where I had Buffy kind of making a pun and being a little bit snarky when I had
to put together,
you know,
it seemed like she was one sort of making fun of Edward for not being tough
enough,
which is not the point of the remix at all.
Um,
and to kind of plays down how dangerous he is.
And I,
you know,
I think it actually,
he is his,
his character and what it represents is it's actually a very dangerous and very
serious.
And so sort of ending on sort of a pithy little,
well,
he doesn't mean anything anyway,
line,
um,
didn't quite fit for,
I wanted to do
[inaudible] that's how I got
the forces of darkness are even trying.
So check it out.
Rebellious pixels.com for more about my work and the more about remix and fair
use.
And,
uh,
thanks for watching.